what the heck is consensus reality and
is it really the answer to everything
you may have seen us mention the subject
before consensus reality after all is
what the scp foundation is trying to
preserve in the face of ever increasing
anomalous activity a kind of truth or
normalcy that all of us can agree on
pick 10 people at random and ask them
what color is the sky what gases element
is produced by trees has every u.s
president since washington secretly been
an alien reptile in disguise the answer
will or at least should be blue oxygen
and no this is consensus reality but
no
not really yes in a more casual sense
the state of reality to which we all
agree could be a viable definition of
the term consensus reality but you
likely don't remember being called upon
for a vote along with the rest of
humanity on what is and isn't quote
unquote normal that's because consensus
reality isn't the consensus of everyone
it's the consensus of the most powerful
beings alive the o5 council in this
instance scp-001
is the ever updating document that
records exactly what normal is but
perhaps even more important is that
anything that exists outside the
council's most recent definition of
normal is targeted for containment while
at face value it seems less flashy than
something like the gate guardian or the
terrifying scarlet king or the insane
twists and turns of the oroboro cycle
the document defining consensus reality
despite being the only thing on the
database to be given the classification
non-anomalous is about as
foundational as foundation documents get
literally everything currently in
containment is there because this
document deems it so it is the scp
foundation's ten commandments of
containment and thou shalt contain if
this document was ever leaked it could
lead to a complete broken masquerade
scenario where the anomalous cat is let
fully out of the bag only the o5 council
has access to the document and it's only
through consensus that additions
alterations or removals can be made
naturally it's a document that's in
extremely high demand among the
anomalous community because it answers
the big question that every anomalous
individual has if i'm not even dangerous
if i've committed no crime that would
necessitate the locking up of a
non-anomalous human why am i still being
contained and don't worry today we're
going to answer that question or rather
the 05 council will but let's return to
the council themselves we've covered
them and their many interpretations
before from them being a group of
fantastical immortal demigods to being a
frightening hive mind to being a shadowy
faction of mysterious emotionless
bureaucrats constantly conniving and
undermining each other to gain just that
little bit more power but what's more
frightening the keys to normality being
in the hands of these larger-than-life
fantastical figures or in the hands of
human beings just as valuable and afraid
as the rest of us with only the
knowledge of the strange things going on
behind the curtain to protect them from
the truly unknowable the l5 council
holds meetings with some regularity
where they ask themselves and each other
whether any new developments in the
wider world require changes to the new
normal it is up to the o5 council to
define the difference between universal
laws gravitation physical forces and
basic chemistry biology sociology
psychology technology and philosophy and
the kind of crackpot theories being
spouted by people on street corners
carrying the end is nice signs some of
their decisions are quite simple can a
new development be explained by the laws
of an existing non-anomalous framework
if so the rules need not be changed the
current paradigm of our understanding
can rest neatly in place but other
decisions fall into a gray area in order
to illustrate this we're going to do
something unprecedented we're going to
go into the actual boardroom of the 05
council and see exactly what decisions
they made about our consensus reality
the one that you and i are living in
right now we're going to look at three
different meetings one from 1932 another
from 1945 and an example from as
recently as 2014
so what really goes on in the
discussions that define what we all
would consider normal the 1932
discussion was spurred on by strange
development happening in the united
kingdom new forms of occult adjacent
witchcraft and spiritualism were
beginning to take off descended largely
from traditional pagan and wicca beliefs
the fact that some of these believers
were actually attempting spells was
enough to catch the foundation's
all-seeing eye and the matter was
discussed by the o5 council oh 5-3 said
why are we even covering this there are
traditional beliefs in culture
throughout history that we do not
consider anomalous we must not use our
position to threaten the right of
humanity to believe with the stern look
05-7 replied except this does not extend
from traditional practices this new
witchcraft is a modern invention
developed through a scholarly re-reading
of practices as an alternative to
christianity it is not a continuation
and practitioners are attempting spell
casting oh 5-5 chimed in with now soon
you'll say aleister crowley has
something to do with it the document is
clear theragy is anomalous religion and
spirituality are not show me proof that
they are casting spells that cannot be
explained under rigorous testing and i
will personally see to containing those
spells myself until then no just as the
lemma is allowed so shall this
witchcraft for god's sake will allow
satanism as long as they aren't
channeling demonic energies oh 5-1 the
most senior member of the council nodded
and said agreed furthermore we will need
all the faith we can muster against the
thergic traditions we never know when a
new faith will assist in our cause no
updates to consensus reality were made
in 1945 an event of far greater
magnitude took place the use of
terrifying new weapons by the u.s
military in hiroshima and nagasaki that
resulted in the deaths of over 200
thousand people the council converged to
discuss the earth-shattering event and
what their reaction to it should be
shaking oh 5-2 said thank you for
responding to my emergency call trinity
has happened i can barely contain what i
saw it was like the sun rising from the
desert sand a dawn of destruction and
fire that lasted for miles around i
cannot believe that such an explosion
could ever be seen as possible tales and
prior evidence of the summoning of gods
of hadley seemed packed i tremble with
fear about the possibility of people
wielding this kind of power the ability
to level a city with the flick of a
switch oh 5-4 replied aren't the germans
and russians also developing this
technology we are at war and this sort
of escalation happens 05-5 said may i
remind my esteemed colleagues that we
are not at war the united states japan
they are at war we are not nations now
the question stands is this anomalous do
the physical effects follow from the
mathematical concepts oh 5-7 said
they do follow scientific testing was
completed each and every step of the way
to reach this point i do not believe
this is anomalous no matter how
frightening the repercussions are 05-2
still understandably worked upset what
you're just going to let people hold on
to the keys to their own destruction we
have fought tooth and nail to keep such
capabilities out of the reach of man and
now you're saying we should abandon our
purpose oh 5-5 said we do not prevent
destruction we sequester the anomalous
and as long as we agree that the test
was arrived through diligent scientific
process available to anyone but 05-2
simply wasn't having it he shot back
available to anyone listen to yourself
man can you imagine a future where any
two-bit dictator chooses to unleash the
fire of a thousand sons wherever he
wishes maybe the problem isn't with the
equations maybe the whole of nuclear
physics is anomalous itself oh 5-1 once
again brought his own level-headed
perspective to the table enrico fermi
has already received a nobel prize for
his work on transuranic elements and
radioactivity we can't just secure
nuclear physics from the world
radioactivity is everywhere and we end
up causing more contradictions when we
try to send ourselves back to the dark
ages try explaining chemistry without
referring to covalent bonds try
explaining biology nuclear physics is
here to stay and we had better get used
to the consequences of this no matter
how terrifying this would be for the
planet and for humanity with a rattling
sigh 05-2 once again took a seat
murmuring may god have mercy on us
in the aftermath of this debate the
document on consensus reality was
altered to reflect these new
developments in nuclear physics as
frightening as they were i think we can
all form a consensus on the fact that
one-off murder is a less depressing
subject than mass murder and it was a
single murder that led to the o5 council
discussing the concept of worms that
walk in 2014 05-6 came to the table with
for those unfamiliar with the topic the
worm that walks is a trope in which a
character is actually a writhing hive
mind of worms generally held together as
a single mass we're not here to discuss
this trope instead we are here to
discuss the recent conspiracy that has
arisen from it the conspiracy is the
idea that certain individuals are
actually worms that walk and not humans
when asked if this conspiracy had any
merit to it 05-6 replied
no individual conspiracy believers are
divided themselves on who is a worm that
walks and who isn't and all evidence
indicates that there aren't actual worms
that walk in the general populace it
pretty clearly falls under
irreproducible conspiracy theories i
personally believe there's nothing we
need to do or change in scp-001
another member of the council wasn't so
sure that these results were
irreproducible saying on december 11
2013 a believer in the conspiracy from
decatur alabama killed his neighbor
under the belief that the neighbor was a
worm that walks the killer then took a
video of his deceased neighbor and
uploaded it to youtube claiming it was
proof of the conspiracy and that the
corpse was dissolving into individual
worms before his very eyes he said that
he was going to take a sample the video
was quickly blocked and removed and
everyone who has viewed the video agrees
that the subject is unmoving and does
not dissolve into worms the killer
turned himself into police while
clutching a jar of tube effects worms
and the neighbor sent to the morgan
county morgue autopsy confirmed that the
descendant was missing a thumb
postmortem and killed by gunshot to the
chest which if he were a worm that walks
would be survivable when questioned
whether these were just the actions of a
single insane man the council member
continued the one item of interest was
that after the autopsy the assistant
coroner oversaw the return of the body
to the next of kin the assistant coroner
was also a conspiracy believer and
despite not having any prior contact to
the parties involved screamed and
discussed upon entering the examination
room grabbing him up and complaining
about all the worms everywhere no one
else noticed any signs of worm
infestation it was further discussed
that d-classes who were shown the body
didn't see it as anything other than a
corpse however after being told about
the worm that walks trump several of
them saw it as a writhing mass of worms
some believe that this could be a
memetic side effect of actually
encountering a living worm that walks
and updates were made to the document to
reference the possible existence of
perceptual monistic worm triggers so now
you know what the o5 council is up to
when not playing office golf or plotting
each other's downfalls they're having
discussions about witchcraft war crimes
and walking worms you're probably
feeling a pain of curiosity about the
actual scp-001 document especially if
you're an understandably vindictive
anomalous individual wondering why the
foundation is carting you off to
paranormal gitmo for the simple crime of
existing and if you look for the true
document and you manage to survive the
memetic kill agents put in place to stop
you then what you'll actually find is
even stranger a letter to you from 05-5
explaining exactly what's happening to
you the letter reads hello i'm afraid
you won't find scp-001 here it's stored
in a far more unreachable location than
this i'm sure you were hoping you could
get in edit it in a couple of places
here and there and voila you're no
longer anomalous you're free to go the
foundation will harass you no longer of
course
it can't be that easy but i'm going to
help you you deserve this much i'm going
to tell you
why
why the foundation targets you why we
deem you something to contain to
persecute after all there are far worse
evils in the world we keep our record of
nuclear weapons above as an example
there are numerous genocides throughout
history the death toll from just the flu
alone is far greater than the potential
damage for thousands of the people and
objects we contain and yet we dedicate
ourselves to branding you anomalous
something not normal something
inherently wrong something that cannot
be allowed its peace why i'm not going
to patronize you and say there's nothing
i can do i'm only one voice on the
council and i can't change things on my
own that's true but the decisions i make
and the way i let myself view your
circumstance are a direct cause of
people seeing fit to throw you into a
box even if i can't change the document
i could remain one more advocate for
your normalcy after all humanity has
believed in ghosts and spirits for
thousands of years we all believe in the
monster under our beds when we were
children these phenomena are very real
and very much a part of the way the
world works why can't we just declare
them normal why won't i free you from
your torment it's because we aren't only
here to secure contain and protect the
world we're here to secure contain and
protect you the defining feature of the
anomalous is that it cannot be explained
through simple scientific testing this
makes you and your nature
different unique even and that scarcity
makes it valuable but that doesn't mean
that your value is something everyone
can appreciate sometimes it can only be
appreciated by those who would use it
against you the scarcity is also the
tool by which a monster can exploit you
others aren't familiar with your anomaly
and won't respond to descriptions about
it as real this gives opportunity to
nefarious individuals to exploit the
lack of knowledge and use you as an
eldritch pawn to their pleasure they can
isolate you consume you make your
anomaly their lever to destroy slake a
sadistic thirst with your existence i'm
sure you've seen it happen someone is
different their desires needs their
reality forces them to be ostracized by
the world at large they're left alone
probably not friendless but sidelined
starved for connection that's when
someone swoops in promising greatness
but only offering that connection you
crave through consumption of you
destruction of your world perversion of
your reality you fight back try to tell
someone of your plight but others
respond well that can't be happening
that's not real you must be mistaken you
are alone in your anomaly and left to
suffer we can't let that happen yes go
ahead point out that we're isolating you
at least as well slowly consuming you
and your existence just as surely as
some abuser might wish to burn you off
call us monsters it's okay but keep in
mind that even in our pursuit of you our
cover-up our incarceration of you we
still want to make sure that you
continue to exist that you aren't
removed entirely from this world you
have every right to exist you have every
right to be as different as you are you
the monsters out there the monsters in
here you are all just as real as we are
just as real as the teeming irrational
self-destructive humanity that remains
ignorant to your plight and the
conclusion that we are all in the end
the same stuff i hope you can find
comfort in it yes you are a monster but
whether we are deemed anomalous or not
so is every last one of us and that
means you deserve your existence we
secure you we contain you we protect you
and even if you still don't get why i'm
doing this please understand that i
still love you now go check out children
of scp-001 the scarlet king is scp-999
really his son and scp-001 or borocycle
the full story compilation for more
perspectives on the everlusive scp-001